i don't want to beat a dead horse by
showing you all of the different ways to
find a determinant but it might be
useful to beat this dead horse because
you'll see it done in different ways in
different contexts and i thought i would
at least show you that what we've been
covering so far is very consistent with
a way of determining or finding
determinants that you might have been
exposed to in your algebra 2 class it's
called the rule of saris and essentially
well let me just prove it for you so
let's say we want to find the
determinant so we want to find this
determinant so our matrix is a b
c
d e f
g
h i
we know how to do this this is equal to
let's just go down that first row a
times the determinant of e f h i
e f
h i
minus b
minus b times the determinant of d g f i
d
g
f i
plus c
times the determinant of d e g h
d e
g h and what are these equal to this is
going to be equal to a so let me write
this to this is going to be equal to a
times
e i e i
minus f h
minus f h and this is going to be minus
b
times d i
d i minus f g
minus f g and this is going to be plus c
times d h d h
minus e g
minus e g and if we multiply this out we
get this is being equal to
a e i
minus a f h
minus b d i
plus right minus times a minus so plus b
f g
plus
c
d h
minus c
e g now let me group the positive and
the negative terms so i have this term
is positive
this term is positive and that term is
positive so we have this being equal to
a e i
plus b f g
plus c
d h those are our positive terms and
then our negative terms are here we have
that term that term and that term so we
have
minus
a
f h
minus b
d i
minus c e g so this is a formula for the
determinant of this matrix right here
let's see what it actually looks like so
let me rewrite it let me rewrite our
matrix
so if we do it in green so we have a
and we wanted to find its determinant so
let me show you something interesting
here
a e i is what
aei is a product of this guy this guy
and that guys you're essentially going
along
that diagonal right there
now what is bfg
bfg you're going this guy this guy and
then you're going all the way down to
this guy so it's like if you imagine
that when you come out of this side you
come out of this side and there's some
video games where you know one end you
end up showing up on the other end like
that it would also be a diagonal or even
a better way to visualize it let me
draw let me redraw these two columns let
me kind of augment this determinant
that's not a official terminology but i
think you'll get what i'm trying to do
so if i write these first two columns
again a
d
g
and b
e h
this guy right here b f g it's this one
right here it's this
diagonal right there and then you might
guess what's about to happen where is
cdh it's this diagonal
it's that diagonal right there so you
take this product add it to this product
add to this product and then you
subtract these guys now what are these
guys
where is the a f h
a f h it's that one right there so you
subtract out a f h and then you subtract
out b d i
b d
i is that one
right there and then you have c e g
which is
c e g is this one
right there
so the rule of saris
sounds like something in lord of the
rings the rule
of saris
the rule of sars is essentially the it's
a quick way or a mem or a way of
memorizing this little technique where
you write the two columns again and you
say okay this product plus this product
for this product minus this product
minus this product minus that product
let's actually do it with a three by
three matrix to make it clear that the
rule of saris can be useful
it can be useful so let's say we have
the matrix we want the determinant of
the matrix one two
one two
four
two
minus one
two minus one
three
and then we have
4
0 minus 1. we want to find that
determinant so by the rule of sarus we
can rewrite these first two columns so 1
2 2 minus 1 4 0. we wrote those first
two columns and to figure out this
determinant
we take so we take this guy
so what is this going to be 1 times -1
times minus 1 that is just a 1 right the
minuses cancel out
plus this guy plus this product right
here i should draw a little bit neater
so what is this 2 times 3 times 4 2
times 3 is 6 6 times 4 is 24 plus 24 and
then we take this guy right here four
times two times zero anything times zero
is a zero so it's going to be plus zero
and then we subtract out
these guys
so you have
four
times four times minus one that's minus
16
it's minus 16 but we're going to be
we're going to this is on the minus side
of things so it's the 4 times -1 times 4
is minus 16 but since we're going to do
a minus on it's going to be plus 16.
so it's 16. then you have a zero times
three times one that of course is going
to be a zero would be a minus zero but
we could ignore it so we could say plus
zero or minus zero same thing and then
you have a minus one
minus you have a minus one
times two times two so that's four times
minus one which is minus four when you
go in this direction from the top right
to the bottom left you're subtracting so
this would be a minus four but since
we're subtracting this becomes a plus 4.
so the value of our determinant is equal
to by the rule of sars
so these guys we're going to have 16
plus 4 is a 20
plus
plus 21 plus 2025
which is equal to
45.
so that actually is i you know i'd have
to say a faster way of computing this
3x3 derivative and i just want to show
you it's completely equivalent to the
definition that i introduced you to a
couple of videos ago